>> Tucker: LAST NIGHT WE
PLAYED YOU LONG CLIPS OF THE
PRESIDENT’S RECENT ADDRESS UP
MOUNT RUSHMORE AND IT MUST HAVE
BEEN THE BEST SPEECHES EVER
GIVEN, SUCCINCT AND CLEAR AND
TRUE.
FOR THAT REASON THAT DEMOCRATS
AND THEIR MINIONS HATED IT.
THEY DENOUNCED THE SPEECH AND
THIS MAY NOT COME AS A COMPLETE
SURPRISE TO YOU AS A "RACIST."
THAT’S A SLOWER LONG DIVORCED
FROM ANY ACTUAL MEETING BUT I
SHOULD, WE SHOULD TELL YOU IS A
FACTUAL MATTER IT WAS A LIE.
THERE WAS NOTHING EVEN
CONCEIVABLY RACIST ABOUT TRUMP
SPEECH, WASH IT FOR YOURSELF.
IT IS NOT A RACIST WORD OR IDEA
IN THE WHOLE THING AND THE ONLY
TIME HE BROUGHT UP CIVIL WAR WAS
TO PRAISE ABRAHAM LINCOLN WHO
THANK GOD WANTED.
NEVER MENTIONED A CONFEDERACY OR
ANYONE IN THE COMPETITIVE MARKET
CONFEDERACY.
INSTEAD HE BASHED PEOPLE.
SENATOR DUCKWORTH WATCHED HIS
SPEECH OR CLAIMS SHE DID BUT HER
SUMMARY OF IT WAS HE SPENT ALL
OF HIS TIME TALKING ABOUT DEAD
TRADERS.
THEY ARE ALL, ACCORDING TO
TAMMY DUCKWORTH, DEAD TRADERS.
PRETTY SHOCKING, UNLESS YOU
THINK WE ARE BEING UNFAIR HERE.
IN THE SAME INTERVIEW
SENATOR DUCKWORTH WAS ASKED IF
WE SHOULD TEAR DOWN STATUES OF
GEORGE WASHINGTON.
WE PLAYED THAT FOR YOU LAST
NIGHT AND WE NOTED HOW GROTESQUE
IT WAS.
ONLY SOMEONE WHO HATES THE
COUNTRY WOULD SUGGEST RIPPING
DOWN MONUMENTS TO ITS FOUNDER.
APPARENTLY TAMMY DUCKWORTH SAW
WHAT WE SAID AND DIDN’T DISAGREE
WITH IT EXACTLY.
INSTEAD SHE QUESTIONED OUR RIGHT
TO CRITICIZE HER AT ALL SINCE
SHE WAS ONCE INJURED WHILE
SERVING IN THE ILLINOIS
NATIONAL GUARD.
THAT’S WHAT PASSES FOR AN
ARGUMENT IN MODERN IDENTITY
POLITICS, THEY DON’T ADDRESS THE
POINTS THAT YOU MAKE, THE
QUESTION YOUR RIGHT TO MAKE THEM
AT ALL.
THE IRONY OF COURSE IS THAT
GEORGE WASHINGTON HIMSELF, THE
DEAD TRADER THAT TAMMY DUCKWORTH
HAS SUCH CONTEMPT FOR ALSO
SERVED IN THE MILITARY.
WASHINGTON SPENT MOST OF HIS
ADULT LIFE UNDER ARMS AND FOUGHT
IN TO WARS.
AT ONE POINT HE LOST A QUARTER
OF HIS ARMY TO COLD AND
MALNUTRITION.
SO GEORGE WASHINGTON PAID HIS
DUES.
HE WAS AS WE MIGHT SAY TODAY A
COMBAT VETERAN.
WASHINGTON ALSO CREATED THE
COUNTRY BELIEVED IN AND
GEORGE WASHINGTON WAS A
GENUINELY GREAT MAN.
BUT TOMORROW IS LIKE
TAMMY DUCKWORTH, WASHINGTON WAS
JUST SOME OLD WHITE GUY WHO
NEEDS TO BE ERASED.
WE NAME OUR CAPITAL CITY
SHARPTON AND CONTINUE.
CHANGE IS THAT PROFOUND DESERVE
A DEBATE, NOT SOME FAKE NATIONAL
CONVERSATION WHERE THEY SCREAM
COMMANDS THAT YOU AND YOU GET TO
OBEY.
BUT VIGOROUS REASONABLE EXCHANGE
BETWEEN ADULTS AND WE WANTED HIM
TO HAVE THAT EXPERIENCE TONIGHT.
BEFORE EVEN CONSIDERING OUR
REQUEST, WE MUST FIRST ISSUE A
PUBLIC APOLOGY FOR CRITICIZING
TAMMY DUCKWORTH.
IN OTHER WORDS, I WILL NOT
DEFEAT YOU UNTIL FIRST TO ADMIT
THAT YOU ARE COMPLETELY WRONG.
KEEP IN MIND, SHE IS ALSO
DESCRIBED AS A HERO.
YET DUCKWORTH IS TOO AFRAID TO
DEFEND HER OWN STATEMENTS ON A
TV SHOW, WHAT A COWARD.
TAMMY DUCKWORTH IS ALSO A FRAUD.
FIVE YEARS AGO MEMBERS OF A VA
HOSPITAL APPROACH TO APPROACHED
TO INVESTIGATE THE WIDESPREAD
MISTREATMENT OF VETERANS.
THE WHISTLE-BLOWER MET WITH
TIMMY SEVERAL TIMES AND REFUSED
TO -- SHE DISMISSED THE SYSTEMIC
CRUELTY INFLICTED ON DYING
VETERANS BY SAYING THAT "THAT’S
JUST HOW IT IS AT THE VA."
THEY WERE HORRIFIED BY THAT
RESPONSE AND ULTIMATELY IN
FRUSTRATION THEY TOOK IT TO THE
MEDIA AND IT BECAME A NATIONAL
SCANDAL.
THIS IS THE PERSON LECTURING THE
REST OF US ABOUT HER MORAL
AUTHORITY AS A VETERAN.
SPARE US.
TAMMY DUCKWORTH IS A CALLOUS
HACK WHO IGNORE THE SUFFERING OF
ACTUAL VETERANS WHEN IT ACTUALLY
MATTERED.
SHE HAS NO MORAL AUTHORITY,
SHE’S JUST A POLITICIAN LIKE THE
REST OF THEM.
SHE WORKS FOR US.
THIS IS A DEMOCRACY.
SHE HAS AN OBLIGATION TO EXPLAIN
HERSELF AND ANSWER OUR QUESTION
AND OUR FIRST QUESTION WOULD BE
HOW CAN YOU LEAD A COUNTRY THAT
YOU DESPISE?
THAT’S NOT SOMETHING WE WOULD
ASK ONLY TO TAMMY DUCKWORTH BY
THE WAY, HATING AMERICA IS A
MAJOR THEME IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY RIGHT NOW.
HERE’S CONGRESSWOMAN ILHAN OMAR
JUST TODAY.
AND IF ANYONE SHOULD LOVE
AMERICA, IT’S ILHAN OMAR.
WE RESCUED HER AND MEET HER
NATIONAL FIGURE.
BUT SHE’S NOT GRATEFUL, SHE
HATES US FOR IT.
WATCH AS SHE TELLS US IT’S TIME
TO DISMANTLE OUR COUNTRY.
>> AS LONG AS OUR ECONOMY AND
POLITICAL SYSTEMS PRIORITIZE
PROFIT WITHOUT CONSIDERING WHO
IS PROFITING, WHO IS BEING SHUT
OUT, WE WILL PERPETUATE THIS
INEQUALITY.
SO WE CANNOT STOP AT CRIMINAL
JUSTICE.
WE MUST BEGIN THE WORK OF
DISMANTLING THE WHOLE SYSTEM OF
OPPRESSION WHEREVER WE FIND IT.
>> Tucker: DISMANTLE THE
AMERICAN ECONOMY AND THE
AMERICAN SYSTEM OF GOVERNMENT?
INSTITUTIONS THAT GENERATIONS OF
AMERICANS BUILT OVER HUNDREDS OF
YEARS?
TEAR THEM DOWN, WE DON’T LIKE
THEM.
WE WANT A NEW COUNTRY.
THE PROBLEM IS THERE ARE MANY OF
US HERE THAT YOU LIKE THIS
COUNTRY.
WE DON’T WANT TO DESTROY IT, WE
HAVE EVERY RIGHT TO FIGHT AND
PRESERVE OUR NATION, OUR
HERITAGE AND OUR CULTURE.
AND WHEN VANDALS LIKE TO MEET
DUCKWORTH AND ILHAN OMAR TELL US
WE ARE NOT ALLOWED TO QUESTION
THEIR PATRIOTISM EVEN WHEN THEY